what's up guys it's football season you
don't like football no problem today
we're talking fake movie sports and
we're going to decide who the best movie
athletes of all time are help us decide
a couple of awesome dudes the schmoes
from youtube.com slash schmoes no doubt
on the end we have mr. Marc Ellis thank
you good to be here had my Wheaties this
morning how it's play ball and Kristian
harloff put me in coach I'm ready to
play so since this football season we're
gonna kick it off with our fantasy movie
football draft we flipped coins and drew
straws it was complicated and Mark Ellis
is going first we're gonna snake back
and forth with pics handsome guys always
win I'm gonna take a quarterback in the
first round here generally you take a
running back but I like my pic here
Johnny Utah from Point Break he was
great with the FBI I am an FBI agent but
we never saw him actually play football
he was in Ohio State he was in a brawl
he said in the beach he threw a couple
pass on the beach and he made a tackle
against Swayze into the water he can go
both ways and he was great at getting
Gary Busey meatballs to to me Bolger
talked to Utah
get me to Christian I'm actually gonna
go with a defensive player I'm doing
with Latimer from the program that's my
team I'll call it the lattimer's
christian i does i do think that shows a
little bit of lacking in your morals to
pick someone who would use drugs like
that but hey anything for a victory it's
right alright so I get two picks in a
row right here and then we go back down
the line so first oh I'm going with
Jamie Foxx screaming Willie Beamen my
name is Reuben
from any given Sunday
yeah when Johnny Utah inevitably goes
down in the second quarter Willie Beamen
can come right in and lead us to victory
my second pick I need a running back I'm
going Tim Riggins Friday Night Lights I
I gotta give some love to Taylor kid
she's had a bad run lately for me I
guess I'm gonna go ahead and I'm gonna
I'm gonna go with a real player Michael
Irvin from The Longest Yard this yard
you picked a guy from the Adam Sandler
Longest Yard he's an actual ho player
I'm a listen I'm not just basing it on
the movie we're basing it on skills you
know I was racking my brain trying to
think of a movie that Bo Jackson
appeared in and I just can't get in so
I'm gonna have to go to the varsity
blues segment and I'm gonna draft
tweeter the wide receiver in the slot he
can get open over the middle he's got
that Wes Welker kind of body I like and
he's gonna pay for drinks at the strip
club after we got our victory all right
then let's take it around again I need a
special teamer so I'm gonna get a great
kicker from long range Kathy Ireland
from Necessary Roughness not only a
great foot honor but she has some other
assets it's going to play well in the
locker room I for my tax but I'll go
quarterback here I'm also gonna go with
a canter Reeves character except this
one from the replacements great to Kia
nose so far gone in the draft for those
who scoring at home okay I gotta go with
maybe the fastest man that any of us
have mentioned Forrest Gump yeah that's
a good one at least we know the fields
gonna be mowed before the game and then
I'm gonna go rod Tidwell show me the
money
yeah yeah Cuba Gooding jr. Jerry buddy
yeah my next pick I think I'm actually
gonna go with a running back as well but
I have to go and pick from the program
again I'm gonna go with omar epps ain't
no statistic in and out bobbin and
Weavin and that's a running back that
you want and we're gonna wrap up our
football picks right here kind of my
wildcard Air Bud that ain't no golden
retriever that is a golden receiver we
call the officials and I want to see
this illegal I think we should call PETA
so we have our football teams now we're
gonna widen it out let's say a group of
robot Marauders came to earth and
challenged our best fictional movie
athletes to a mega castle on we're going
any sport any athlete yes this is an
easy one for me Michael Jordan from
Space Jam thank you we win it
the case I'm gonna pick Mike Tyson from
the hangover Ellis picked Michael Jordan
Asst and one spacing oh um he cornered
the market got the best basketball
player who's better than Jordan Teen
Wolf you're going Scott Howard Teen Wolf
he's got ridiculous ups he could surf on
top of a van my second pick I'm going
Rudy who's gonna inspire team more than
Rudy I just don't want him complaining
about playing time it's nice to have you
on the sidelines but you're not actually
getting into the game it's too important
a sky for the lock well I like I like
controversy on my team as I have proven
so far so I am going to pick Ricky the
wild thing Vaughn from Major League just
a bit outside I am ready to watch this
guy throw 120 miles an hour at people's
heads I'm taking the fat kid from the
Sandlot he's got to be on any sports
team you talk about he can block the
plate he can block a hockey goal he can
block a soccer goal okay the kids on the
team and then I'm gonna go two for one
with my next pick I'm gonna go Wesley
Snipes and Woody Harrelson there are two
for one package from white men can't
jump I like humor on my team as well too
so I'm gonna take Corey Feldman from the
Bad News Bears well I thought much Bad
News Bears is he he was like six in the
one like the first or second one so you
picked Jordan but I'm gonna pick the
guys that almost defeated Jordan going
with the Monstars gonna say I shouldn't
even brought up Jordan unstoppable and
then he can get by any rules
Juwanna Mann oh you got kicked out of
the league but then he played with the
women you want to pick another pick no I
am riding do you wanna Mandeville
victory you talk about hard that you
want to be on the court pretty bad if
you wear that wig you just pick my leaf
my last pick I think in single handedly
just beat the Monstars on their own the
Hanson brothers from slap shots not the
Hanson brothers sing oom bop no they
were though they would break those
Hanson brothers over their knees they
fight everyone they're maniacs he didn't
say much and that's what I need them on
yeah but don't worry how the Hanson
brothers can play the halftime show
great thank you
well speaking of nuts and we want
somebody that's a multi-sport athlete
somebody that can take all the
aggression you get in hockey and then
clean it up in a nice eloquent game like
golf so who better for a last pick than
happy gilmore
that's your home are you too good for
your home and to me I don't know how
we're gonna use him on the team yet but
he's there and he once stabbed a guy
with his ice skates he's like your goon
there's our teams let's take a look at
our football rosters one more time got
mark Alice's oh that's a great-looking
list Kristian harloff on a two year old
horn a little bit sexy and there's mine
on beatable and now the teams to go up
against robot Marauders in the mega cat
hole here's Mark Ellis's Kristian
harloff and mine maybe I should not have
taken Rudi with my second pick so there
you have it we got all these teams who
picked the best squads football mega cat
blond leave your comments in the section
below best comment it's a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank my pals Mark
Ellis and Kristian harloff the schmoes
no show super funny film reviews lots of
good stuff thank you for watching I'm
Hal Rudnick bye bye
it'd be awful why I just doesn't have
the range he's not a good actor Batman's
from Gotham Ben Affleck's from Boston
don't make no sense
Gotham's not a real place you know Oh
pinochle